[Music]
check out Angelina Jolie enjoying a
one-of-a-kind HBCU experience with
daughter Zahara at spelman's homecoming
I'm so excited I feel like my world
expands as their World Experience yeah I
learned so much from them and yeah I
love this stage
it all went down over the weekend in
Atlanta at Zahara a freshman at Spelman
had her proud mama by her side she's
growing up so beautifully Jordan Berry
who snapped a selfie with the actress on
campus tells ET quote I walked up to her
and said I know you're Angelina Jolie
and I want to get a selfie but I don't
want to create a scene so when we take
this picture I'm going to hold the angle
down here and I'm going to look you're
going to look and we're going to smile
and then just take off with Jordan
adding that Angelina's response was
quote great plan I'm happy that they're
able to have some fun with it Jordan
says Angelina was just enjoying the
space she was in quote she was not
trying to stand out and just seemed like
a normal College Mom with her daughter
her daughter was showing her around the
tailgate they both seem to be having a
good time when your children are your
best friends it's kind of a it's a nice
life speaking of Zahara showing her mom
around the tailgate check out this fan
and honor with Angelina and here she is
in the ground of the brown jacket
with her family
[Music]
[Applause]
the whole family I don't know what size
to bring everybody
Angelina's visit to Spelman comes after
she got emotional dropping her daughter
off at the school in August all right
Miss Jolie can you tell us how does it
feel
how does it feel to be able to spell my
mom
and who can forget this moment
when Angelina attempted to do the
Electric Slide alongside zahara's
classmates and alums she even shared
this photo of Zahara with her Spellman
sisters writing quote congratulations to
all new students starting this year a
very special place and an honor to have
a family member as a new Spelman girl
happy homecoming Sahara
foreign